try and notify it like you want with
wildfires burning in the western united
states
and a heat wave intensifying droughts
u.s president joe biden convened a
meeting with governors
on what to do about it we know this is
this is becoming a regular cycle and we
know it's getting worse
in fact the threat of western wildfires
this year is as severe as it's ever been
temperatures are soaring on the west
coast of the united states and canada
cities like seattle and portland known
for their moderate temperatures
are breaking heat records and struggling
with water shortages
in vancouver canada the heat wave is
being blamed for more than 60 deaths
with the toll expected to rise
with wildfires now a year round not
seasonal problem biden told governors
he's giving firefighters
a pay raise to 15 dollars an hour
to help keep western states staffed and
prepared to fight fires
whenever they hit the truth is we're
playing catch-up
but his administration also announced
it's doubled the funding to help cities
prepare for extreme weather disasters
among other initiatives to combat
climate change
in his 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure deal
worked out with republicans in congress
the extreme weather events americans are
experiencing year round
underscore the need to make bold
investments
needed to tackle the climate crisis the
bipartisan infrastructure framework
would make the largest investment in
american history
but some members of biden's own
democratic party
protested outside the white house this
week accusing biden
of cutting many of his climate change
policies to please his conservative
critics
with democrats controlling congress and
the white house
they're pushing for biden to do more
they want the biden administration to
aggressively reduce fossil fuels
and protect federal lands they argue the
1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure bill
needs to have much
tougher standards on power plants and
encourage
more electric vehicle technology i don't
think
it's achievable i think the president is
doing this right
he's appealing to to moderates within
the republican party which is
right climate change needs to stop being
a democratic thing
and being an american thing last year's
wildfire season in the united states saw
more than 4 million hectares of land
burned
and dozens of people killed and this
year is predicted to be
even worse as communities struggle with
a new
normal record warm seasons that start
sooner and last longer kimberly hellcat
al jazeera washington